HARRIS WILL DELIVER REMARKS FROM
INSIDE THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING WE SEE THAT
OFTEN, A PRESIDENT SPEAKING
INSIDE.
WANT TO BRING IN CHIEF
WASHINGTON CORRESPONDENT AND
ANCHOR OF "THE LEAD" AND
CO-ANCHOR OFF "STATE OF THE
UNION," JAKE TAPPER.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT HOW INCREDIBLY
PRESCIENT YOU WERE, CHILLINGLY
PRESCIENT YOU WERE ONE YEAR AGO
TODAY.
WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN IN A SECOND.
ONE THING WE'RE TOLD HE'S GOING
TO SAY IS HE'S GOING TO ASK ARE
WE GOING TO BE A NATION WHERE WE
ALLOW PARTISAN ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO OVERTURN THE
LEGALLY EXPRESSED WILL OF THE
PEOPLE?
THAT'S WHAT HE'S GOING TO ASK.
THERE ARE 163 REPUBLICANS
RUNNING FOR OFFICE AROUND THE
COUNTRY THAT WILL CONTROL
ELECTION APPARATUS THAT ARE
BUYING INTO THE BIG LIE.
SO THE QUESTION MAY BE -- THE
ANSWER MAY BE, YES, THIS COUNTRY
MIGHT BE PUTTING THOSE PEOPLE IN
OFFICE.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN, IT DOESN'T
MATTER AS MUCH WHAT HE SAYS
TODAY AS WHAT REPUBLICAN LEADERS
SAY GOING FORWARD.
WE, AS JOHN AVLON JUST POINTED
OUT SO ELOQUENTLY IN THAT PIECE,
WE'RE AT A POINT NOW WHERE -- I
MEAN, DONALD TRUMP, ONE THING HE
DID DO DURING HIS PRESIDENCY, HE
MADE THE VERY CONCEPT OF FACTS
AND INSTITUTIONS, HE TURNED THEM
INTO PARTISAN ISSUES.
RIGHT.
SO JUST REPORTING A FACT BECAME
A PARTISAN DEBATE, EVEN IF IT
WAS JUST A FACT.
AND NOW HE'S DOING THE SAME WITH
OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
HAS DONE THE SAME WITH OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
A YEAR AGO WE WERE ALL HORRIFIED
TO SEE WHAT HAPPENED.
YOU HEARD THE REPUBLICAN HOUSE
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY BLAME
TRUMP FOR THE MOB, SPECIFICALLY
CLEARLY, CONCISELY, AND NOW HE
WILL NEVER CRITICIZE DONALD
TRUMP.
HE -- THE WORDS THAT HE SAID
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP BEARING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE VIOLENT
MOB THAT ATTACKED THE CAPITOL,
THAT VERY CONCEPT THAT HE
HIMSELF SAID, KEVIN McCARTHY,
WERE I TO SAY IT NOW, COULD SEE
KEVIN McCARTHY CRITICIZING ME
FOR BEING PARTISAN.
EVEN THOUGH I'M JUST REPEATING
HIS OWN WORDS AGAINST HIM.
WE NEED REPUBLICAN PATRIOTS, NOT
JUST ADAM KINZINGER AND LIZ
CHENEY, WE NEED REPUBLICAN
PATRIOTS TO STAND UP FOR
DEMOCRACY.
AND WE NEED THE CONSERVATIVE
PUNDITS WHO KNOW BETTER TO STOP
BELITTLING WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th.
I THINK IT WAS CONSERVATIVE
WRITER KEVIN WILLIAMSON WHO
SAID, OF COURSE, THE RIOTS THAT
WE SAW IN THE CITIES THROUGHOUT
2020, OF COURSE THEY WERE
HORRIFIC, OF COURSE THEY WERE
CRIMINAL, BUT THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A COUP D'ETAT
AND COUP DTARGET, THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE.
>> IF YOU READ THE OP-ED OUT IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMTIMES" BY JIMM
CARTER, HE SAYS IT TAKES
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS COMING
TOGETHER, BUT THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING.
FINISH THIS SENTENCE AS YOU
DESCRIBED THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
ONE YEAR LATER, THE STATE OF OUR
UNION IS --
>> TEETERING.
ABSOLUTELY TEETERING.
AND IT IS NOT JUST JIMMY CARTER
WHO HAS DEVOTED MUCH OF HIS POST
PRESIDENCY PERIOD TO STANDING UP
FOR DEMOCRACY ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND NOW IS CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
HE'S SEEING IN HIS BACK YARD,
YOU HAVE KARL ROVE, THE
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST, I THINK
HE STILL WORKS FOR FOX, TALKING
ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS WHO
ENABLED THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL.
AND WE NEED MORE STATEMENTS LIKE
WHAT WE'RE SEEING FROM KARL
ROVE.
NOW, IT CERTAINLY NOT AS FULL
THROATED AS WHAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM JIMMY CARTER.
BUT WE NEED REPUBLICANS TO STAND
UP FOR THIS.
WE NEED THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
REPUBLICANS, WHO SO BRAVELY, SO
VALIANTLY FOUGHT FOR DEMOCRACY,
FOUGHT FOR HUMAN RIGHTS ABROAD,
AS MEMBERS OF  OUR MILITARY, WE
NEED THEM TO HAVE THAT SAME
COURAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
STANDING UP FOR DEMOCRACY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> SO, JAKE, EARLIER IN THE
SHOW, WE RAN A MASHUP OF CNN'S
COVERAGE OF JANUARY 6th.
YOU WERE ON DURING THAT ENTIRE
TIME, WATCHING, WITNESSING THE
ATTACK ON THE BUILDING BEHIND
US.
BUT I WANT TO PLAY ONE MOMENT,
WE SAT UP STRAIGHT WHEN WE HEARD
YOU SAY THIS, THIS IS YOU ONE
YEAR AGO TODAY.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> TRUMP SUPPORTERS HAVE STORMED
THE U.S. CAPITOL.
THERE ARE VIOLENT CONFRONTATIONS
GOING ON.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS HAVE BEEN
TOLD TO SHELTER IN PLACE.
THERE IS GOING TO BE AN ATTEMPT
BY THE PEOPLE WHO WERE PART OF
THIS EFFORT, PRESIDENT TRUMP,
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY, SENATOR TED CRUZ,
SENATOR HAWLEY, ET CETERA, THERE
IS GOING TO BE AN ATTEMPT TO
WHITEWASH WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
>> YES.
YES.
I MEAN, YOU WERE RIGHT.
>> WELL, THAT'S NOT PRESCIENT.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING THE CROCODILE
IS GOING TO TRY TO EAT THE DEER.
THAT'S WHAT THESE PEOPLE DO.
THEY HAVE BEEN LYING, JOSH
HAWLEY, TED CRUZ, KEVIN
McCARTHY, DONALD TRUMP, THESE
PEOPLE LIED ABOUT THE ELECTION.
AND THEY HELPED INCITE WHAT
HAPPENED.
ALL OF THEM.
IT IS, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH OF IT WAS COORDINATED
AND THAT'S FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE TO DETERMINE.
BUT IT ALL WAS OF THE PEACE.
YOU HAVE DONALD TRUMP, STAGING A
MONTH'S LONG CAMPAIGN TO TRY TO
UNDERMINE THE ELECTION THROUGH
VARIOUS MEANS.
SOME OF THEM LEGAL, AND THEN
TURNING INTO NOT LEGAL
POTENTIALLY EVEN CRIMINAL, SUCH
AS TRYING TO SHAKE DOWN THE
GEORGIA SECRETARY OF STATE.
AND THEN YOU HAD PEOPLE LIKE TED
CRUZ AND JOSH HAWLEY AND A
MAJORITY OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS
SIGNING ON TO THAT DERANGED
LAWSUIT FROM THE TEXAS ATTORNEY
GENERAL THAT MADE CRAZY
ALLEGATIONS ABOUT THE ELECTION,
TRYING TO REMOVE STATES'
ELECTORAL VOTES FROM COUNTING,
BASED ON LIES, BASED ON JUST
ABJECT LIES, SAYING THAT
PHILADELPHIA USED ELECTION
SOFTWARE THAT IT DID NOT USE, ET
CETERA, ET CETERA.
YOU COULD DO A WHOLE SHOW ON THE
LIES IN THAT ONE LAWSUIT.
THEN AFTER THAT, EVEN AFTER
BLOOD WAS SPILLED, EVEN AFTER
THERE WERE BODIES IN THE
CAPITOL, THEY VOTED TO NOT COUNT
THE VOTES FROM PENNSYLVANIA AND
ARIZONA.
AND DID ANY OF THEM -- ONE OF
THE BEST THINGS, MOST TELLING
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
HAPPENED IN 2021 WAS FROM
CONSERVATIVE TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
CHIP ROY, VERY CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICAN, WHO DID NOT SIGN ON
TO THAT CRAZY LAWSUIT AND DID
NOT VOTE TO UNDERMINE THE
ELECTORAL VOTES.
BUT A HUGE OPPONENT OF JOE
BIDEN, AND A HUGE SUPPORTER OF
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT HE SAID, HE OFFERED
LEGISLATION AND I'M
PARAPHRASING, BUT IT WAS
BASICALLY, IF YOU ARE VOTING TO
UNDERMINE THE VOTES FROM
PENNSYLVANIA AND ARIZONA, YOU
ALSO HAVE TO VOTE TO UNDERMINE
ALL OF THE FEDERAL ELECTIONS ON
THOSE SAME BALLOTS BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT WOULD
BE INTELLECTUALLY CONSISTENT.
VERY TELLING LEGISLATION FROM
CONGRESSMAN CHIP ROY THERE.
OF COURSE, NOT ONE OF THE
REPUBLICANS FROM ARIZONA OR
REPUBLICANS FROM PENNSYLVANIA
WHO VOTED TO UNDERMINE THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION FROM THEIR
OWN STATES VOTED TO UNDERMINE
THEIR OWN ELECTIONS TO CONGRESS
ON THE SAME BALLOTS ON THE